>> President Trump: WE ARE
PROUDLY SUPPORTING THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
INCLUDING OUR WONDERFUL ICE
OFFICERS AND BORDER PATROL
AGENTS.
THESE ARE INCREDIBLE PEOPLE WHO
ENDORSED ME DURING THE CAMPAIGN
AND THEY ARE INCREDIBLE.
[APPLAUSE]
THEY'RE DOING A GREAT JOB AT
THE BORDER, BY THE WAY.
WE ARE GOING TO END CHAIN
MIGRATION.
WE ARE GOING TO END THE LOTTERY
SYSTEM.
AND WE ARE GOING TO BUILD THE
WALL.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: WE NEED TWO OR THREE
HUNDRED MILES OF THAT WALL BY
EARLIER THE PRESIDENT PROMISED
TO REFORM OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM THAT IS BROKEN.
LAST MONDAY CALIFORNIA BECAME A
SANCTUARY STATE WHEN THE LAW
TOOK EFFECT PREVENTING STATE
AND LOCAL POLICE ABOUT ASKING
PEOPLE ABOUT THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS OR COOPERATING WITH
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES IN MOST CASES.
WATCH THIS.
♪
>> WERE YOU AWARE CALIFORNIA IS
A SANCTUARY STATE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS?
>> OF COURSE I KNOW THAT.
IMMIGRANTS TO BE PROTECTED.
BEING A SANCTUARY STATE IS
PERFECT.
>> WHY ARE WE MAKING IT
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO BECOME
LEGAL?
THEY DON'T PAY THEIR TAXES AND
DON'T DO WHAT YOU COMPLAIN
SO WHY NOT MAKE IT LEGAL FOR
LABOR THEN WE ALSO HAVE TO GIVE
THEM THE BENEFITS THAT EVERY
AMERICAN CITIZEN BENEFITS HAVE.
>> BEING AN IMMIGRANT FROM
WORKERS TO TAKE CERTAIN JOBS
THAT MANY CURRENTLY EMPLOYED
I LOVE IT.
I'LL ADMIT I HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS AND MYSELF THAT ARE
ILLEGAL.
I MEAN JUST BEING FREE YOU ARE
OUT HERE TRYING TO DO YOURSELF.
>> DO YOU KNOW IT WAS A
SANCTUARY STATE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS?
>> I DID.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> I THINK WE NEED TO COME UP
WITH AN IMMIGRATION BILL THAT
WILL SOLVE ALL THE PROBLEMS AND
HELP IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY TRANSMIT AND BECOME
U.S. CITIZENS.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD
COME OVER HERE.
YOU SAID ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS?
I DON'T THINK THEY -- THEY
SHOULD STAY WHERE THEY ARE AT.
WHY DO THEY HAVE TO BE OVER
HERE?
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THAT HAVE DONE IT
THE RIGHT WAY AND PAID A LOT OF
MONEY AND WAITED TIME TO COME
INTO THIS COUNTRY.
DO YOU FEEL IT INVALIDATES
EVERYTHING THEY WORKED FOR TO
LET ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS RECEIVE
SANCTUARY IN CALIFORNIA?
ONE CAME FAIRLY AND ONE CAME IN
A SENSE --
>> UNFAIRLY?
>> IT IS NOT SUCH A BLACK AND
WHITE THING.
THEY CAME TO FEED THEIR
FAMILIES.
>> IF THE LAWS AREN'T BEING
ENFORCED IS THAT A PROBLEM?
>> IT'S ONE OF THESE
UNENFORCEIBLE LAWS.
IT TOOK 3 1/2 YEARS TO COME TO
AMERICA.
I THINK EVERYBODY SHOULD GO
THROUGH A PROCESS.
>> THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN AROUND.
THEY'VE ONLY BECOME PART OF
THIS POPULAR CONVERSATION
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT SOCIETY
HAS ATTEMPTED TO VILLAINIZE
IMMIGRANTS.
>> THEY DO IT ILLEGALLY BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MEANS TO
GET IN OR A SAFER WAY TO GET IN
EITHER.
WE ALSO HAVE THE RULE OF LAW.
>> IT IS MY STATE, SEAN.
WHAT CAN I TELL YOU?
>> Sean: 13 1/2% INCOME TAX
RATE IN THE STATE.
DOESN'T TEXAS AND FLORIDA, THEY
HAVE PRETTY GOOD INFRASTRUCTURE.
BETTER THAN NEW YORK.
WHY IS THERE THAT OVERWHELMING
FEELING.
IS THIS A CALIFORNIA THING TO
YOU?
FLORIDA AND TEXAS AND ELSEWHERE
BECAUSE OF THINGS LIKE IT BEING
A SANCTUARY STATE.
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU,
BREAKING NEWS, CALIFORNIA IS
THERE ARE SO MANY UNDERCOVER
CONSERVATIVES IN THIS STATE
THAT I SPOKE TO THAT ARE LEVEL
HEADED THAT DON'T LIKE THE FACT
IT'S A SANCTUARY STATE.
SOMETIMES THERE ARE OTHERS,
THOUGH, THAT ARE A LITTLE
LOUDER.
SQUEAKY WHEEL GETS A GREASE A
LOT OF TIMES.
>> Sean: WHY SHOULD THEY GET
FEDERAL TAX DOLLARS IN ANY WAY
IF THEY ARE LITERALLY AIDING
AND ABETTING LAW BREAKING AS A
STATE?
>> THEY ABSOLUTELY SHOULDN'T.
THERE ARE A LOT OF CALIFORNIANS
INTO THE WHOLE PEACE, LOVE AND
WELCOME EVERYONE UNLESS YOU ARE
TOMI LAHREN AND FOX NEWS.
THEY WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE
IMMIGRANTS HAD TO SPEND A LOT
OF MONEY AND WAIT A LOT OF TIME
TO GET INTO THIS COUNTRY AND
INTO THE STATE.
THEN THEIR TUNE CHANGED A
LITTLE BIT.
IT WAS QUITE FASCINATING.
>> Sean: I WAS REALLY
INTERESTING AS I WAS WATCHING
THIS PACKAGE YOU PUT TOGETHER
AND I'M INTERESTED THAT A LOT
THE OTHER GUY IN THE GRAY SHIRT
AND I'M THINKING HOW WAS THEIR
THERE ARE A FEW OF US THAT ARE
CONSERVATIVES THAT SPEAK.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY EVER MET
ONE BEFORE.
>> WELL, I WANT TO BE FAIR.
WE DID ENCOUNTER A LOT OF
REALLY RESPECTFUL PEOPLE THAT
LIKED WHAT WE DO ON FOX NEWS.
I SPENT TIME IN WEST HOLLYWOOD.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
IT'S A VERY LIBERAL AREA.
IT IS THE EPICENTER OF THE
RESISTANCE.
AND THEY CERTAINLY KNEW WHO I
WAS AND THERE WERE SOME WORDS I
CAN'T REPEAT ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION THEY WERE SCREAMING
AT ME.
THEY SAW THE FOX NEWS MIC AND
WEREN'T THRILLED WE WERE THERE.
THEY TOLD US TO GET OUT.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE THE
LOVING AND TOLERANT LEFT
WELCOMING EVERYONE UNLESS YOU
ARE FOX NEWS AND TOMI LAHREN.